The federal minimum wage of $7.25 an hour
has not been raised since 2009. That’s the
longest period without an increase
since the minimum wage was enacted,
meaning today’s minimum wage is actually
worth far less than it was in 2009.
This is an insult to American workers,
and bad for our economy. It’s far past
time to raise the minimum wage to at least
$15 an hour. Today’s minimum wage is a
starvation wage. A full-time minimum wage
worker cannot afford a two-bedroom rental in any
city, county, or state in the entire country.
Meanwhile, billionaires like Jeff Bezos can afford
a D.C. mansion with 25 bathrooms and 5 living
rooms — just one of his many mansions. Now, the
current minimum wage isn’t so low because these
workers are “worth” less than they were years ago;
quite the opposite. If the minimum wage had kept
pace with workers’ productivity increases
since 1968, it would be $24 an hour today.
Even so, conservatives are out to
scare you about raising the wage.
Let’s debunk each of their talking points.
Myth #1: If businesses have
to raise wages, they’ll cut
employees’ hours or cut jobs altogether.
Rubbish. Since at least the 1930s,
critics have argued that setting any minimum
standard of decency at the workplace will raise
employer costs and kill jobs — child labor laws,
the 40-hour workweek, and workplace safety laws.
Look: Treating workers decently is worth the
price. Besides, an abundance of research shows
that increases in the minimum wage do not reduce
the overall number of jobs. Researchers examined
138 state-level minimum wage increases
and found that the number of low-wage
jobs remained essentially unchanged in the five
years following the increase, but paid more.
That’s a job upgrade, not a job loss,
and multiple studies have come to the
same conclusion. When I led the fight
to raise the minimum wage in 1996,
many conservatives predicted huge job losses.
Well, I’m happy to report that after the increase,
almost 10 million low-wage workers received a
raise with no decline in overall employment.
It’s simply a myth that raising the
wage automatically means lost jobs.
Not to mention the benefits for workers
themselves. Raising the wage to $15
an hour by 2025, as proposed in the Raise the
Wage Act, would give 32 million workers a raise.
Here’s the bottom line: If your business model
depends on paying your workers starvation wages,
you should not be in business.
Myth #2: Small businesses won’t be able to afford
the higher wage and will be put out of business.
Baloney. The fact is, a higher minimum wage can
actually lower costs to small businesses. How?
For starters, a higher minimum wage attracts
more potential workers into the labor force,
thereby giving employers more choice of whom
to hire. This leads to higher productivity
and better service. Better service means more
satisfied clients and customers. Higher paid
workers are also more likely to stick around,
saving businesses the hefty costs that come with
recruiting, hiring, and training new workers. A
study of the San Francisco airport confirms this:
researchers found that following a wage increase,
a majority of workers who received a raise
improved their overall performance. The higher
wages even led to shorter airport lines.
Researchers also found that employee turnover
declined by 34 percent -- saving employers an
estimated $6.6 million a year. Smart
business owners understand this. Henry Ford,
after introducing the “five dollar day” in 1914
when the typical industry wage was less than half
that, called it his best cost-cutting strategy
because of the productivity boost that followed.
Myth #3: If the wage is raised, prices for
everything will skyrocket and lead to widespread
inflation. Wrong again. Researchers have found
that for every 10 percent increase in the minimum
wage, prices increase by less than half a percent.
And it’s a temporary price increase — occurring
only in the month the wage hike goes into
effect. No way this sparks inflation.In fact,
the minimum wage needs to be raised so
that it can catch up with inflation.
Because of inflation, the minimum wage is now
worth almost a third less than it was in 1968.
And since it was last raised in 2009, it’s
lost 17 percent of its value. This means that
compared to 2009, minimum wage workers have lost
$3,950 every year. That’s why a higher minimum
wage would boost economic growth. 70 percent
of the economy depends on consumer spending,
so more money in people’s pockets means they can
spend more on the goods and services that keep the
economy going. Oh, and raising the minimum wage
would reduce the amount of money taxpayers spend
on public assistance that families need because
their breadwinners don’t make enough to live on.
It’s estimated that nearly half of
federal minimum wage workers’ families
are enrolled in at least one safety net program,
costing the public $107 billion every year.
That’s right: our tax dollars are subsidizing
corporations that don’t pay a living wage.
Myth #4: Most minimum wage workers are teenagers
making some extra money on the side; they don’t
need a wage increase. More rubbish. While this
might have been the case in 1968, it certainly
isn't now. Today, only 1 in 10 workers who would
benefit from a $15 minimum wage is a teenager.
More than half are between the ages of 25 and 54.
More than half of them work full time, and over
a quarter have children. Today’s starvation wage
hurts people who are in their prime earning years,
preventing them from building wealth and
establishing financial security. building wealth
and establishing financial security. Raising
the minimum wage would also help reduce racial
and gender pay disparities. Minimum wage
increases and expansions in the late 1960s
reduced the income gap between Black and
white workers. because Black workers,
Hispanic workers, and women comprise a large
portion of today’s low-wage workers. In sum,
raising the minimum wage is good for workers,
good for businesses, and good for the economy.
In addition to all this, raising the minimum
wage is the morally correct thing to do.
It ought to lift working people out of poverty,
not keep them in it. We’re the richest country
in the world, home to the richest people on the
planet. We can, and we must, treat our workers
with the dignity and respect they deserve.
That starts with paying them a living wage.